on gère encore c'est malheureusement
cette crise sanitaire et ce qui retarde
quand même assez considérablement les
projets que l'on voulait lancer dans
l'immédiat alors pour l'instant on est
sur la lancée de ce que nous avions pu
faire je dirais dans la mandature
précédente là on va achever le gymnase
on espère pouvoir inaugurer notre
gymnase au mois de septembre mais rien
n'est gagné 1
ensuite on termine et on va terminer
aussi l'agrandissement du cimetière on
pense pouvoir travailler en commun on
verra dans les commissions
en tout cas on espère que ça avance en
là on est un petit peu on a été un petit
peu frustré décès de moins avec kobe
d'où l'opposition a pas eu trop son mot
à dire
on a eu ce petit besoin de d'information
on n'a pas eu pendant ces deux mois on
espère que ça va être résolue dans les
prochains concerts